[Música]
boa tarde meu tema preconceito e
violência contra as pessoas em situação
de rua porque o interesse nesse tempo o
quinto ano
nós tínhamos uma tarefa onde é nós
trazemos uma notícia que tinha ocorrido
na semana inicial minha mãe comprou um
jornal e que logo na capa já tinha uma
notícia de uma pessoa em situação de rua
que foi morto por pedradas e início
falei nossa que brotou e lendo todo todo
todo o jornal
eu acabei me interessando muito por esse
tema aquele tema foi o que mais me chama
atenção e quando surgiu a oportunidade
do tédio falei a minha oportunidade e
mostrar pro mundo meu é meu tempo que eu
estudei e foi nisso que eu trouxe a
notícia
o que você faria se estivesse em
situação de rua
você já pensou nisso
é o que você faria provavelmente não
iniciou várias outras coisas me fizeram
é é trazer esse tema
você só porque estão na rua geralmente
são problemas com drogas é casos de
alcoolismo é discussões familiares e até
mesmo causa de distúrbios mentais
a violência está passando dos limites
nessa imagem tem mostra que uma mensagem
falando não possuir um teto não faz -
humano e parece que tem gente que não
entende isso porque é entende que como
tenho é menos dinheiro não tem um lugar
para morar
acaba entendendo que é não é pessoa não
gente então por isso é deve ser tratado
com desrespeito e até mesmo matando e
pesquisando só um pouco em alguns sites
que entre o jazz
a notícia é sobre brutal total mesmo
tanto que dá nojo e eu vou poupar vocês
dessa nessa imagem é a figura em preto
que é mostrar o assentimento seres
humanos as emoções e nós os nossos
sentimentos estão ignorando
completamente as pessoas em situação de
rua e isso é um grande problema no mundo
não só no brasil todo mundo ignora eles
não todo mundo aposta que tem gente aqui
que ajuda eles mas muita a maior parte
do mundo e ignora eles completamente e
isso é preocupante porque cada vez mais
que vai surgindo é geralmente é a
situação deles é pior e isso vai
acumulando acumulando acumulando até que
é chegar num nível que a gente nem pode
imaginar nós como ajudar assim como eu
você pode estudar o sistema
compartilhado informações que você
estudou ajudar as pessoas da situação e
simplesmente dizer oi que isso pode
alegrar o dia delas
e pra finalizar eu vou nessa tinha o
estudante chega por uma pessoa em
situação de rua e fala bom dia senhor
bom um dia eu já tinha até esquecido que
ainda exista que a gente ignorando
completamente eles e isso pode é causa
eles esquecimento da vida deles
obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]